so uh read more codes that's rm
and uh it's uh actually uh
i was lucky to have a nice set of
collaborators it's actually two
different joint works so the first one
is with amir spirka and avi vinderson
the and the second work that i'll talk
about is with uh yuval victorson
who is an undergrad student in princeton
so harry and your relationship
yeah a pretty direct relationship father
and son
other son and holy spirit
so um okay i it seems like
it's good to give some intros so i i
prepared an intro quickly this morning
um
it's inspired by a comment from dave
forney at the banquet
last week at ita and uh by david
t time remarks so
i'm not i don't have the expertise to
give an historical overview of coding
so don't take as you will see these uh
too rigorously so in 48
coding is born with paper of shannon
and that's the problem of uh
capacity and it shows you can achieve it
there's this code
with a random random argument
probabilistic argument and then lots of
activity to achieve this capacity
embossing the worst case and the
probabilistic model
algebraic codes and many great
developments
but no good codes and for some time
and hard to get to capacity unless you
allow
an exponential blow up in the gap to
capacity with for example concatenation
codes
and this might be the end of the story
in fact so there was this conference
in the 1970 which became famous because
it's referred to as the coding theory's
dead conference
uh people saw that we had reached a
point of diminishing return
but is that true i think we are
proof uh that's not quite so
including uh theory wasn't dead they
came back from the grief and uh
again uh new ideas uh lots of good
people uh
graph based codes uh uh are
show up with me technique like tcs
people come and join
the troops with expander codes but still
exponential blow up etc
but then in the 90s uh
message passing algorithm on the old
ldpc codes of gaggers
seem to in fact get to capacity or at
least
they are very satisfying so uh again in
the 90s with this new wave it seems like
this time
coding is dead so that's the end
at least we said so uh because it came
back again and uh
adapted to new technologies and new
trends
but uh it finally got finished uh
properly uh with spora codes
another 20 years after so it's a pretty
recurrence
because polar codes shift capacity and
blow up his polynomial in the gap to
capacity
if you had doubts it was there the
vancat came with a stick and make sure
it was polynomial
it was not moving anymore so
um at least okay you know the story i'm
a bit embarrassed to say that
that's what we saw but not quite it's
still a little bit there
these polar codes have the scaling law
as an exponent of four
random codes can get two so rudy and tom
uh come up with a special couple
but it's three so uh but there's
something which is new
instead of a new a construction that
maybe
might be the better one and keep going
it seems like uh
the very old read border codes back in
1950s
seem to actually achieve capacity it
might even have an exponent of two like
random codes so they might behave like
rhythm codes
there's still a chance to decode them
but uh the funny joke in the sense that
maybe coding was dead in the 50s but we
just
didn't know it so the difficulty is to
is to
establish this claim that coding that
rhythm records that shift capacity and
also then
if you can efficiently decode that so
this talk part of it is to
corroborate this claim and give some
result towards that
conjecture so that's the serpent's key
matrix
i i saw that name once and i thought it
was a good name for this matrix because
you see the surface
triangles on the right is just the
tensor product of the one one zero one
so n is the dimension if you do log n
tensors
and uh there's a both power codes and
with miracles are obtained by you take a
subset of the rows of that the matrix
and then
you stack them up together and now
whatever you generate from that
subset of rows gives you a code and also
a question is how do you generate a good
subset of rows
so what is good uh so let's first see uh
oh actually interesting that's the note
slide
sorry about that
i forgot to skip it
so rhythm records what they do is they
look for the rows of
largest weight okay it's a very simple
uh
rule very easy to parse the matrix from
this
and what polar codes do which is pretty
smart is that okay
taking larger suede seems to make sense
for example if you care about distance
that's the best thing to do
but um if we want to achieve capacity
why don't we sort of cut corner and go
for what we want which is
extract information because we need we
know in a sense we
need all the information to to be
extracted to to be capacity achieving so
formally uh if you are the talk of that
are you try to make the mutual
information between the is bit
and the transform bit so these are
the output of the channel the user the
transform bit through the
full squared matrix you want to pick
those rows that have these high
mutual informations one
observation if you like to think of read
more code and try to compare them with
sport code you can
also say that by maximizing the weight
what you're trying to do is maximize the
hamming distance
between the weight of the i throw to the
span of the previous rows
so the high level rhythmicals are the
worst case or hamming best way of
choosing the rose
you always try to push yourself from the
span of the previous wars
and the other ones are the shannon
version of it so it makes sense that
this one are going to be
easier to prove to achieve capacity
what's funny is that read molar codes
they have the best distance that you can
think of as a subset of rows of this
sequence
matrix why is that is because each time
you pick a row of a given weight you get
for free all the other rules of that
weight so that's
why rhythm records would be the best way
to to minimize the amming weights
but they're bad codes for the worst case
model they don't have a
relative distance that is a
non-vanishing at the given rate the
fixed rate
whereas polar codes we know they are
worse distance but they are
designed to achieve capacity but the the
funniest thing is that
it seems like despite the fact that they
are constructing for distance they seem
to also achieve capacity
and then if this is true because they
have a better distance they might even
do better performance at the finite
block lengths they will
but that's if you can do maximum
likelihood decoding
except that they will have a better
finite log lens performance
so the goal of the talk i'm probably
already how much uh
sometimes i spent on this 10 minutes
that was pretty long
so sorry started at three right so
a little a little bit after syrian here
in about 10 minutes you have 20 minutes
okay so the two thing i want to discuss
is
yes they do achieve capacity in some
regimes i'll tell you what the regimes
are
and the other is uh what would be other
constructions that you could think of
from this matrix
so what's our measure of good uh i'll
discuss only the case of the binary
erasure channel for this talk and
maybe mention some results for your
errors
so a good proxy for the bc so this is
going to be a fairly basic stuff of
coding
that's just the way i like to look at it
okay if you want to code on a bc
of parameter p that means that you have
roughly p times n random erasures in a
block of links n
uniformly at random roughly and
if you want to measure the property of
error of a given code
because of the symmetry it's enough to
look at the property of error that you
have if you send the old zero code word
so assuming you send the old zero code
word then
a bad ear erasure pattern that i
represent with stars here
is one for which there is a no there's
another code word like here which is not
the zero chord
that you transmitted but such that you
can cover with the erasure pattern see i
cover all the ones here
because if you do that then you will
conf you don't know if the
if you what you are observing is all
zeros so you cannot deduce if this is a
zero code word of this guy so
so what does this mean i want to uh
translate that in terms of the party
check matrix
so here's the partition matrix you may
wonder why do i draw the same figure as
what i was discussing before which was a
generator matrix
but for read miracles they are the same
this is the same actually construction
but in any case this is just a flat
matrix the code is the null space of
that matrix so
every vector you multiply on the right
that goes to zero
and uh we just said that we want to make
sure that if we select
a number of erasures so it's like
selecting columns here i cannot cover a
code word
which is exactly equivalent to say that
this column should be linearly
independent
if there are dependents then you can
come up with a way to
do a mixture of them that goes to zero
which gives you a code word
okay so uh
okay so this what is this property the
what we are looking for
in the worst case is the least number of
columns that are independent that's
exactly the distance of the code
it's also sometimes called the curse of
the matrix
not to be confused with the curse of the
code when you do the tanner
representation this is just the rank of
a matrix is the largest number of
generally independent columns and the
girth is the least number
of linearly dependent columns i'll tell
you in a second why i
equate girds so now let's define the
probabilistic girls
which is i'm maximizing over that
parameter between 0 and 1.
this is the sampling parameter for each
column so i pick each column in that
matrix is probably s
and then i obtain a sub matrix the red
one here and ask what is the largest s i
can have such that with high probability
when n tends to infinity
my matrix or my sequences of matrices
are going to be
having linear independent columns okay
so super super over s is a number
between the rain one and i call this the
prior stickers so the reason why i uh we
call it girth at first we thought okay a
good name
for this would be probabilistic distance
because this is the distance
exactly this is a priority distance but
it's misleading because if you think of
this as a processing distance
it's not true that if you get half of
this processing distance you can
correct errors there's there's an issue
it doesn't replicate
from worst case to for high stick so
let's just call it gears for now
and achieving a capacity on the bc is
just saying that the kappa
the pcm your party check matrix of the
code should have a relative rank which
is of the same order of the
priority girls so it's a this is nothing
again they're new it's just reorganizing
things and
the message is that if you have a matrix
which is your
it's supposed to design your code if it
has that property
that you can take p n columns
uniformly at random and with high
probability they are linear independence
and if the number of rows of your matrix
which is the rank assuming uh we don't
take
a matrix with redundant rows is close
to the number of columns you can pick
then you are highers that's what we call
higgers optimal
the best you can hope for so what is a
good matrix that achieves this tiger's
property is a random uniform matrix
with high probability you will be
highers
and the code achieve capacity on the bc
if you have that aggress property
on the matrix it does for the partition
so it's also like the another name for
this would have been probabilistic mds
because mds is the worst case model and
this is but
again it's just achieving capacity on
the bsc
okay so now uh there's the question
that i said i will discuss the first is
what is a good role selection to get
this high gross property
so the game is we have that serpent's
key metrics how do you select a subset
of rows
so that we are highers and highers for
some
ratio that is uh between zero and one
for the rank they're actively the other
one is when are read more code highers
because the point is uh you can see you
see it doesn't have to be um
you can ask this problem when p is
constant in which case this is growing
linear
but the exact same problem isn't well
defined mathematically when p
is not constant when you just call this
p times n a number s
s could be growing a square root of n
you have the same problem how many
can i pick close to square root of n
columns so that you're i'm
literally independent with high
probability so uh that would just
mean achieving capacity on the bsc with
parameter p erasure parameter p depends
on n
and goes to zero and then you can also
go to one so you can
you can study these uh general these
regimes where p doesn't have to be
constant
and what we will do is the following we
cannot prove that the result for a fixed
p with rhythm are codes but
we're going to start with a p that are
like
maybe a small and then grow grow as long
as we can actually get
the result to hold
okay so uh we'll give a very quick
construction first i'll tell you a bit
about the construction for getting
hikers matrices
which is inspired by polar codes and
then i'll tell you what we get for red
more codes
so the first paper is a archive is with
yuval
it's irish matrices and polarization
here is the idea like in polar codes
do something similar except that there's
no channel we're gonna i'm gonna
describe a process which is intrinsic to
that matrix
there's no channel there's no erasure or
probability or bsc or anything
you look at the first i minus one rows
of that matrix
pick the next row that's a subscript i
and the other one is upper script
and i'll define this conditional rank as
the probability that if you subsample s
n columns so you pick each of them is
probably s
the vector you obtain green in the blue
row is linearly dependent independent of
the previous
vectors and you for the first row you
assume you have the zero
uh the whole zero raw stack up to
initialize something
can you repeat the definition so you
subsample s n columns and ask what is
the property that this vector that is
obtained by this
guys here is very independent that all
these vectors that you already have
selected in that green matrix that is
before
from the red the projection yeah
so this is purely algebraic fact there's
no mutual information or entropy
but it turns out that this is exactly
the same as the process which is a bec
process the mutual information of the
channels that we
if you were to apply this transform as a
code on the bc channel
so just to see why this this holds
so see let's just look at the case of
the 2x2 matrix
if you want to uh make sure that uh
remember i said you for
the first row you assume there's the
zero zero on top you want to make sure
this is a linearly independent
well as long as you pick one guy then
you're good so you just want to
make sure you don't have this that
happens which is 2s minus s square
and here if you want to make sure that
this is not independent of that then you
have to pick both if you just pick
0 or just pick one then you are linearly
dependent and this will be a square you
have to pick both so
2 s minus s square and s square is the
first two iteration the first two
numbers you get
when you do dimension two if you want to
apply this thing for dimension four
the nice trick is that you just iterate
those two functions here and here
so the same happens again and again like
in powder codes
and this is exactly the same that what
you get for the bc process but you don't
need this for now because as you can see
that this is a built-in
proxy to get that property of highers
it's a few lines to see why you get
higher so it's like
there's some competitions but that's the
motivation as a result we get that icor
matrices are rigors
by high core i mean that i make sure
that i only keep the row so okay i
skipped something important
uh for people i assume people know power
codes this is going to polarize this
process
so if you iterate that process log n
times you get
n values these are the n conditional
ranks from all these rows
and you tend to zero or one so the
fraction of uh
components that are not extremely
vanishing
so now what you to construct the highest
matrix you just keep the ones that have
some
conditional rank that are non-negligible
you pack them and this gives you a
higher matrix
for any s that you you start with
so what does this tell us
so first of all uh well nothing new in a
sense because i
just told you they were the same as the
bc process so you get the same code
construction as power codes it's just a
new view
i call this a high school level proof so
uh
maybe uh uh that's for good high school
student but
what i mean by high school is not it
doesn't mean it's trivial
but it's just linear algebra you can
construct that code
by just no you just need to know linear
dependence
so the rank and the girth which is and
then you can construct a good which is
fully explicit uh
it will have low complexity and log n uh
framework on the bc don't care about the
decoding and
it's uh it achieves capacity uh yeah
yeah so no uh so so
i would say like i said in san diego in
fact sorry if you're in saginaw there's
overlapping stock
uh you need you need the black box of
telatar which uh like get rid of
martingales and you just need orthogonal
increments so you can do algebra there
so you do algebra there you do now you
don't even need mutual information
you don't need to talk about channels
it's just purely
algebraic and that's that that
gives you something anyway uh maybe so
it's nothing you accept perhaps
it is a bit uh interesting that it's a
bit more general than bc
it's an intrinsic property of the matrix
but it works for any field you don't
care that it's gf2
it even works over the wheels or any
arbitrary field
in fact for example you can use this for
sparse recovery
because it works on the reels you can
construct matrices that uh for
probabilistic sparse recovery
so it's a bit more generalized so maybe
that's a plus
and uh it doesn't achieve capacity on
the bc but uh it gets some uh
rates oh yeah it also that's for maybe
polar code
people it also gives you an operational
meaning to this batacharya
upper bound process when we do polar
codes for errors
we have this z 2 z minus z square
process that we play with all the time
if it's bc this is exactly the major
information but uh or the butcher of the
channels but otherwise it's an upper
bound when this is like uh
giving a meaning to it it's this process
is there are conditional ranks
okay so that's that was a bit on the
polar code side and now i'll tell you
the result we have for read more codes
uh that's the paper it will be presented
in stuck in uh
in a couple of months and uh the results
first so the notation is uh
the usual notation r m r
m so what does this means
um read more codes you can define them
the way i did here
which is through the serpentski matrix
and keep the
highest weight but you can also look at
them
as a evaluation of multivariate
polynomials of bounded degree
so if you take the polynomials
of degree that most are
on m boolean variables
so this is a linear space a polynomial
of boundary degree
you evaluate them on the hypercube so
there's two to the m code words
there's two to the impossible vectors
and um and you will get exactly the same
code as the one i described before it's
the rhythmer codes but
this is the parameters r for the degree
and m for the number of variables
you don't get very good rates though
right
this is not constant rate it's not it's
not a matter of
it's not uh it's not getting good rates
because it's capacity achieving it
it's we are not in the regime of
constant property of error it's not the
same
questions you see the difference it's
not that you are suboptimal this is
achieving capacity it's just that
you are not in the regime where the
property offer is constant
yeah you are it's as if you're in the
corner but then you ask the question are
you tight are you achieving capacity in
that
regime so there's no question that uh
it would be great if we could get the
constant rate that's the the thing we
would like to do
but in the meantime let me tell you what
we could do it's a
r can be a little law of m i think we
have results for uh
a constant times m but it's not exactly
capacity achieving there's a small
dependency
maybe we could get a small constant
let's say m to a thousand for example
that
that could be doable but if you want to
get to constant rate regime you need
that uh the rate has to be exactly m
over two for example that's rate half
so m over three is very different than m
over two
m over 2 is a constant rate m over 3 is
no longer a constant rate because
so we are we can maybe go linear in m
but
not for sure to m over 2. and
there's a two capacity results here for
the bc
uh this one is sadly less good so what
does this mean this is a small degrees
so that's a
that would be a low snr regime no
scenario okay that's
that's a lots of errors or erasures and
that's high snr
this is typically harder like in coding
theory it's always harder to work at the
high center clean channels
but there's a capacity result here okay
this is not the capacity result so these
are these are checks
means it works this is a square root so
we can
you can roughly correct a square root of
the number of errors uh than what you
could do with a capacity
so the techniques are uh
different for the the the four results
this is the most work
in a sense but the hardest because bsc a
high scenario
for the lowest snr it's uh based on the
weight and numerator oh yeah
maybe some results so surprisingly
there's very little result about
a capacity achieving uh rhythmic code so
if you really want to
be able to back off for any epsilon or
one minus epsilon the optimal rate and
succeed
we only know this for r is equal to one
which is just the orthogonal codes
just the first row and it took quite a
bit of work uh
to get the result for r is equal to two
so when i say there's no result that say
that really makes our capacity achieving
i should actually say there is r is
equal to two
and uh now we can push it to uh m
uh divided by log m and uh and here so
the techniques here is weight enumerator
techniques
and uh and then applying it uh usual
bounds uh
from eighteen numerators and um with
maybe some a little bit more careful
works to make uh
this thing work with that scaling and
there we mainly use five minutes or
three minutes okay here we mainly use
the this is
extending a work a very nice paper by uh
kaufman
lovett and porat where they get this
bound of this kind except they have r
here instead of
dependency where l so this is the the
notation here is that
this is the relative weight of the code
word and is counting how many code words
you have up to that relative weight
and here we could push it from constant
to m over four
uh using the similar techniques it's
basically uh the
the technique that is based on proving
that the
polymers are bounded the degree you can
approximate it well by having a few
derivatives that's
and then you you push that but what i
want to discuss in the last two minutes
is this one which i think is
an interesting case and
here is the picture so that's the red
motor codes
for m is equal to four so the way you
can construct the square separation
matrix but with another permutation of
the rows is as follow you put all the
hypercube here all zero vector all one
one
and now i just evaluate all monomials of
first degree one
the degree zero degree one degree two up
two degree four maximal degree
so when you evaluate degree one you
always get one x one gives you the first
row in that matrix here in the
in those vectors etc
so now this if you were to apply a
permutations you would get back serbian
scale but it's a different way to
organize it
so with mirror codes you just keep the
rows up to about a given degree let's
say 2 here so that's
our that's rm 2 4.
and now uh let's say that we have picked
k columns
s sorry s columns already uniformly at
random and assume they are linearly
independent
and i want to check that higher property
so i would like to
control what is the property that if i
pick a new vector at random
i am in the span of the previous columns
and i will do an inductive argument to
compute the property that k columns are
independent so how how we do this
what does it mean that this new column
here in red
is in the span of the previous column so
i put upper script r to specify that
the dimension of these columns is this
right the sum
i is equal to 0 up to r of m choose i
so it's roughly like if r is a constant
this is like m to the r
so it's power the first id
the goal is to use the intuition from
polynomials so this is not just an
arbitrary matrix
they are evaluation of polynomials
so being in the span so i'm adding those
guys as being the span
means the following if you would like to
express this
ex this property here that you are in a
span
as only a property that depends on those
evaluation points
not the vectors but the points that you
are hitting
uh in the sort of pre-image
and this is what it is um asking that
the evaluation vectors are in the span
is asking that those evaluation points
that the new one you're going to draw is
a common zeros of all polynomials that
are defined on these variables
so i'll just quickly explain this and
then we
wrap up quick
so to be in the span of these columns it
means that
another way to say that you have a flat
matrix and you are
in the span of all these columns is the
same to see that if you take a columns
and multiply on the left
you have to be orthogonal to all these
columns
now being orthogonal means that i call
this the vector f
the vector f times all these columns
let's call u r
r equal to zero inner products
but having a vector on the left here is
like picking
uh a collection of this monomial it's
like defining a polynomial
it's not hard to see that this is
exactly equivalent to say that the
polynomial defined by
the indicator function at the vector u
is zero so it's like evaluating this
fundamental q
so this is what the this observation is
we are asking what is the property that
we pick a new
evaluation point and it's a common zeros
of all these polynomials that are
defined on these guys
so this brings you to train to study
how many common zeros can a set of
polymers have
and uh if you want to show that this set
of common zero is large then
s must be large and you have exactly the
converse results to
prove that this must be so small right
because if
s must be large then you can have an
argument if you
if you have too many s then this guy
must be small by the
converse argument so how do we show that
the set of common zeros is large when
you have enough
polynomials at the beginning well then
the next idea is to
show that if you have enough vectors in
the hypercube
then you can up to some linear
transformation map them into a humming
ball
so why do we care about the humming ball
then i'll not explain how we get the
humming ball
well look at this is the arming ball for
example here the up to weight of
two so there's a whole vector of weight
one and all vectors of weight 2.
if you look at the evaluation of this
harming ball you get the identity matrix
here
and the identity matrix here that's
pretty easy to check is hamming ball
maps directly to identity matrices so
these vectors are all linearly
independent because of this property
that the identity matrices
are right there so if you have a numbing
ball at least that simple one then you
get linear independent vectors
which is what we want to get the problem
is that we don't necessarily have a
hummingbird at the beginning but
by having enough vector we are forced to
have at least some numbing ball
somewhere
and what is this kind of argument is
hashing
so so the end it's a hashing argument
how do we deal with the fact that you
don't uh have it exactly but you have it
up to linear transformation
with the fact that read miracles are
environment and they're defined groups
so there's a few steps in the
in between but that's the idea so you
can use either left over ash lemar from
impossible b
or in fact you get the slightly tighter
bound by using another paper which is uh
by a
way a very nice paper that characterizes
the generalization weight of read more
codes
oh yeah and yuri asked me
emmanuel everybody talks about risboro
codes but are they even practical
so they are because they were used in
the 60s to send a picture of mars
with the mariner 9 vessel so that the
answer is yes
people would have used them yeah you're
asking why don't they use them they use
them
send a picture of mars
because samsung patented the second
order
so actually it's a famous thing because
then
then the international trade commission
gave the rights to samsung but then
obama overall
well i'm thinking i'm late